Sony's widows in New Orleans
I Sonny welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi mister day thank you for listening to
me sure I'll come home well I just
finished my first year of college
currently I'm debt-free
I'm going to school no debt good I've
stayed about 200 to $450 a month I have
twelve hundred dollars in savings so I'm
like a good path as far as putting my
emergency fund away time of 36 months of
savings aside just in case of an
emergency however I was offered an
opportunity to move to Charleston with a
friend of mine and go live there and go
to school there and I guess what I'm
asking you is I'm worried that I'm going
to be missing out on opportunities
because I'm so worried about my finances
what are the opportunities you're going
to miss well I held off on going to a
university and staying on campus and
like experiencing the college lifestyle
but a couple of years ago but now I have
the opportunity to move there and just
kind of be independent and on my own
rather than living at home and to be
funny well it all comes down to whether
you can pay for all that right so I'd
probably have to open up a loan and that
would be about fifteen to thirty
thousand dollars a year let's be real
clear you're talking about borrowing
money to have the college experience not
to get an education right that's absurd
okay and see that's what I've been
following you since um since I was 16 so
I really know what I should be doing but
I want to make sure that I'm not missing
out on operation
you're not missing out on opportunities
you're missing out on some parties oh
well I don't mind you going to some
parties if you if you have the money to
pay cash but basically you're telling me
that and you're telling yourself you're
saying this out loud that you're talking
about going into student loan debt to
live away from home
and have the college party experience
the freedom experience this hasn't got
anything to do with getting an education
now if you can do that and pay cash for
it I don't mind you doing it and having
that experience but that's not an
opportunity that's Disneyland for
college students right opportunity is
education opportunity is the ability to
go into the marketplace and make money
that's an opportunity playing is luxury
that's not opportunity you can't call it
opportunity that's improper word for to
describe this so I appreciate you
calling me and you sound like you're
very very mature beyond your years and
you kind of knew what I was going to say
and you kind of just wanted me to say it
and so I did don't do this unless you
can pay cash for it you're not missing
out on anything except the heartache of
a student loan that's the big thing
you're missing out on don't have the 28
year old you looking at the 22 year old
you going you stupid fool you financed a
party don't do that that you don't want
you don't want to cut yourself later
you're too smart for that Sonny you
really are you're wise beyond your years
and I think you know what the right
thing to do is now if you can change the
financial situation and somehow make
this work with that alone
I don't care then they'll do whatever
you want to do it's not a bad thing to
go away to college and have the college
experience it's not a horrible thing
it's not a immoral thing or a sinful
thing or anything like that there's
nothing wrong with it but the idea to
borrow money to do that when you've
already got your education tracked out
well that that tells us exactly while
we're borrowing money hey thanks for the
call you do the right thing you know
what to do an amazing number of student
loan dollars go exactly to that in
America today have a 1.3 trillion dollar
student loan crisis and a lot of it
bought the college experience
this is the Dave Ramsey show